hello i'm kaylee spaney and i play lily
i'm lovie simone i play tabby hi i'm
gideon i play frankie
and i'm zoe luna i play lourdes and
today we're with buzzfeed to take a quiz
to find out which character from the
craft legacy we actually
are
which element do you connect with most
we have
earth water air fire
i'm picking fire which i'm curious what
you guys are all gonna pick because we
all have the same
under the same elements i chose fired
some aries
we're all fire signs
i chose fire because i'm fired go with
air because like i'm pretty crazy like a
gemini
i'm pretty extreme like an aquarius and
i'm also into like looking good like a
libra
i see that for you choose another witch
to join your coven
the original the og sabrina from sabrina
the teenage witch
got bonnie from the vampire diaries luna
lovegood
and harry potter and willow rosenberg
from buffy i'm the worst and i haven't
seen
any of them except for harry potter so
i'm gonna go with luna
i really i love luna like i went like
this when i said her name
i'm gonna go ahead and say sabrina from
the teenage witch because that's the
only one here that i saw
and i love her style and personality so
she's pretty chilly like
girl i'm going with my lesbian bestie
willow rosenberg
from buffy you already know how much i
love fun
she follows the rules she's basically
lourdes but a redhead in white
love her if you could have one power
which would you choose
the power to get rid of pimples the
power to get rid of period cramps
the power to repel stains from your
clothes the power to know exactly what
you're in the mood to eat dang these
were hard but
i think my power is going to be to get
rid of
period cramps i think i'm going to do
the one
the power to repel stains from your
clothes because i get stains
on everything and i always borrow my
boyfriend's
sweaters and i always get ketchup or
mustard
or some [ __ ] on it haley and i are just
choosing the same things
but i was going to the power to repel
stains from clothes because i also feel
like i could do that
with my couch because i bought a white
couch
i guess i would choose the power to know
exactly what
mood i'm in for food because i can never
decide i either want
chicken fries burger pizza sushi
or curry i'm going to go with that pick
a tune
to get you in the witchy mood
a bad guy by billy eilish dystemia by
rihanna
heads will roll a track remix but
the yeah yes there will be blood by kim
petrus
trans icon legend i'm definitely doing
disturbia by rihanna because throwback
a bad guy by billy eilish because i just
like that beat it's just like
wow it's just all bass like yeah
yeah i'm a bad guy because i feel like
it makes you witchy like i want to be
like this
i'm gonna go with bad guy because i
think billy is just hot and i want her
to be my girlfriend
she's a witch from the craft sarah
bailey
nancy downs bonnie harper and rochelle
zimmerman nancy downs all the way
queen legend bonnie harper because she's
pretty
iconic i'm just gonna go with sarah
bailey because
i kind of like how she came into her
power i think i'm gonna go with rochelle
because of reasons we all know
she's supporting my girls and
i just like what she did to that white
girl in the film with the hair if i
could have done that in high school i
would have done it like 10
times which crafty halloween treat looks
the most appetizing
clementine pumpkins margulie pizza
oh it's so cute pigs in a mammoth
blanket cyclops slices
margarita pizza that looks so
good i'm going with pigs that help
blanket
i'm gonna go with the margarita pizza
pick an animal familiar
a cat a snake a toad or rabbit
rabbit
[Music]
i got tabby i got lily
i got a tabby i'm fired literally you
have a sparky disposition that draws
people in
but it's that same tude that makes you
i got lily mine says you may seem shy
and timid
but beneath the surface is a powerful
boss ass witch
opening up to new people is a little
hard for you but once you find your
squad
you're bonded for life i don't know
about you intimidated maybe in my head
i'm so happy i got tabby tabby is so
cool
i don't think i'm cool enough to be
tabby but i'll take it
you